[Music]
[Music]
hey man
oh hey charlie what's up
what do you got there oh this
uh ancient calamity i've been waiting to
play this one
that's that multiplayer nope
uh i mean i don't think
[Music]
says so with that
let's go
have you ever wondered what it's like to
play a co-op zelda game with someone who
barely knows anything about zelda lore
someone who needs to look at their
controller when you tell them which
buttons to press
then i have good news for you since
everyone and their mother
is streaming or let's playing age of
calamity i thought i'd join in on this
trend
however i will not be doing this alone
together with one of my best friends
chapsy we will be playing through the
game in co-op mode
so if this is your thing head over to
chapsy's channel
and join this amazing experience in all
of its 15
fps glory also if you like splatoon
smash bros or anything else nintendo
really combined with a sprawling
personality give this man a sub
you will regret it but chepsy doesn't
care he just wants your attention
yeah i said it charlie you [ __ ]
love you buddy
so age of calamity that was quite a ride
wasn't it
after completing the game's story and
most side quests i think it's time to
give my actual
unfiltered opinion on the game a couple
of things up front
know that i enjoyed this game a great
deal i have plenty of positives but also
a fair amount of criticisms on it
both of which will be mentioned and
addressed i also want to quickly say
that i'm leaving out any negatives in
terms of technical or performance issues
the reason being is that i think that
the line share of these issues are not
to be blamed on the game
but rather the switch itself being
underpowered so let's start with
gameplay the gameplay is good i mean
it's still a muso game of course which
is predominantly
known for its straightforward hack and
slash style but it's cool to see that
the game actually made quite tecmo step
outside of its own comfort zone with
things like the divine beast sections
something you don't find in your average
warriors game at the same time i can
also
understand those who decided to skip the
game because they aren't fans of the
hack and slash genre
although the combat is more flashy and
fluent it definitely pales in comparison
to the freeform and creative combat
found in breath of the wild
but i think that there's enough for most
people to get through the main story and
enjoy the gameplay all the way to the
end
mainly due to the variety of weapons to
use characters to take control of
and upgrading your gear and your combos
sure if you only stick to link
throughout the entirety of the main
campaign
yeah it definitely will get stale at
some point since there's only so many
enemies to fight and combinations and
moves to perform
so i would definitely advise to switch
it up and try out different characters
and weapons as you go
it's how muso games are generally meant
to be played they give you a ton of
options to play around
and experiment with i know some people
feel disappointed that there wasn't a
lot of exploration in the game
but to be honest those people probably
didn't know what these types of games
are
if you are familiar with the warriors
franchise that expectation wouldn't have
been there
i've even seen some people who confused
age of calamity with the sequel to
breath of the wild
and yeah if you approach the game with
that misconception i totally get why it
seemed
disappointing but don't worry breath of
the wild 2 is still a thing
it's coming someday lastly i will say
that for the average completionist out
there the game will provide
plenty of stuff to do outside of the
main story you got your weapons to
collect plenty of extra characters to
unlock korok seats to find god help us
all and just
well look at how much stuff there is to
do in terms of side missions
not to mention a pretty extensive post
game trying to reassemble terrico
while again the missions don't provide
the greatest variety
it's enough to give the game a good run
time but as i said before
if all this stuff isn't really your cup
of tea and you're just here for the
story
i definitely recommend skipping this one
and just watching the cutscenes here on
youtube
speaking of which let's talk about the
story because i have a lot to say
now before we get into the actual
narrative i will just say that this is
by far
the biggest and most epic story ever
depicted in a zelda game
and this is mainly due to the
presentation the game is filled with
these hell yeah moments where you just
get totally invested in what's going on
on screen
moments like when hyrule's army stands
on the fields of central hyrule all
races united
is something i've been wanting to see in
a zelda game for a long time
it genuinely gave me goosebumps overall
the cutscenes are simply done
very well with a great mix of epic
touching and comedic moments sprinkled
across the story missions
one of the key elements to the cutscenes
feeling a lot better than in any of the
mainline games is that the characters
are much more lively
expressive and given even more of a
personality than they had previously
which leads into another thing that age
of calamity greatly improves upon
the voice acting in breath of the wild
the voice acting was
very hit or miss sometimes it was good
sometimes
okay and other times just not
good which is why the game really
surprised me since most if not all of
the old cast from breath of the wild
made a return coupled with some new
additions i'm very happy that they went
for this already established cast and
gave them another chance to bring these
characters to life
because man the improvements are so
noticeable
for example just listen to the
difference in yunobo's voice between
games
[Music]
don't worry about that i'm here to help
it's night and day and can i just say
what a job well done by joe hernandez if
i didn't know that daruk and yunobo had
the same voice actor i would have never
guessed
big props to him for being able to
portray two characters with such
radically different voices i mean he's
basically having a conversation with
himself here
as for the rest of the old cast i was
definitely feeling it a lot more this
time around
impa was great especially since she
didn't sound like a young woman trying
to do an old woman's voice this time
being able to play a younger character
definitely made her shine a lot more
and i'd say she did a good job rivali
and herbosa were already good in breath
of the wild and they are great here as
well
even characters like mifa and zelda both
of which i wasn't really the biggest fan
of in breath of the wild in terms of
voice acting managed to convince me a
lot more here
and of course we cannot forget king rome
who really brought it home for me
here now go forth
and be praying for your kingdom
hearing him put on this mighty
thunderous voice during his speech at
the beginning was
amazing and i also really liked having
him as the main story narrator in
between missions
but the ones who really stole the show
for me were the new additions to the
cast
astor koga and suga were just totally
spot on
i love the over-the-top disney
villain-esque performance given by astor
and koga and suga really complimented
each other
koga being the sly deceptive yet silly
leader
and suga representing the more serious
and dangerous side of the yiga clan
sure not all performances were as
memorable but none of them stuck out as
flat out bad
also did riju change accent between
games
seems you have something rather
interesting there
we've come so far we must persevere
until the battle is done
and although they didn't play as big of
a role as i thought they would
robbie and pura's voices were also very
satisfying
all of this also really highlights the
missed opportunity breath of the wild
had when it came to its story
although being a very different game i
think it definitely could have used
cutscenes of this caliber
and i genuinely hope that nintendo will
carry this part of age of calamity
through in breath of the wild too
i mean can you imagine ganondorf with a
voice on par
or even better than that of koga suga
and astor
it would be magical but enough about
that it's time to talk about the actual
narrative
now i'm not gonna lie when i first
finished the main campaign
i felt like the story was a total
cop-out as someone who's been looking
forward to seeing the story of the
calamity play out ever since the
announcement of the game
yeah i really felt like they danced
around the brutal aspects of the event
in retrospect however the story has
managed to grow on me over time and in
hindsight i get why nintendo chose to go
this route with the narrative
now you might think i'm just fanboying
here and being biased by giving the
story a pass but i can assure you that
this is not the case
i mean i literally made an entire series
illustrating how the events of the
calamity played out and predicting how
and where they could add gameplay
sections
if there's anyone who wanted to see the
true story of 100 years ago
it's me but i'm also reasonable enough
to realize that we may have just been
a bit too naive thinking they would
actually depict a horrific event like
this in a zelda game
spin-off or not this is still a nintendo
game we're talking about and the actual
events of the calamity as we know it in
breath of the wild is just
really really dark we're talking
genocide here
townsend civilians getting obliterated
by the thousands with no help of
salvation
it's one thing to recount a story like
this and another to
actually show it and aside from that i
can also understand that they may have
ran into some massive hurdles in terms
of the gameplay
how do you make an enjoyable game where
you end up losing in the end
characters you invested so much time in
leveling them up and upgrading their
equipment suddenly not being playable
anymore because they died
i'm pretty sure we all have our own
ideas and suggestions but
it can't have been easy that being said
i do understand that some people may
have felt misled
by nintendo's marketing of the game and
i will admit that they didn't exactly
make it clear from the very get-go that
this was not actually going to be the
events of the calamity as we know it in
breath of the wild
in fact they made it sound like that was
actually the case and not an alternate
version of events
which is a perfect segue into one of my
biggest gripes with the narrative
the inclusion of time travel now i don't
necessarily dislike
time travel in fact some of my favorite
movies and series feature it in some
shape or form but i would be lying if i
said that i haven't grown
a bit tired of time travel as a plot
device i've just seen it happen
too many times at this point anytime
something terrible happens something
tragic that seems irreversible
boom time travel i don't much care for
the fact that the series as a whole has
to deal with another timeline split
in fact i've never cared that much for
the timeline in general
i acknowledge its existence and i do
bring it up from time to time as it's
unavoidable but i'm generally more
interested in the mysteries and the
secrets which are more contained to one
specific game and heck we don't even
know if there's going to be any sequels
to age of calamity's timeline so it
might be just a one-time offshoot
my biggest problems with time travel is
that a it takes away any meaning of
consequence
why should i care about some tragic
event taking place if i know
in the back of my mind that time travel
is always an option
and b time travel is such an intangible
concept from the perspective of real
life logic and reason
it tends to turn a narrative into a
complete mess when you really start to
think more about it
and brings about stuff like the song of
storm's paradox and other
inconsistencies here are some examples
of some of the stuff that went through
my mind while playing age of calamity
okay so link doesn't have the master
sword yet but i thought creating a
champion said that he got it when he was
like 12 or 13 years old
did he just not get the sword in this
timeline no but wait that doesn't make
sense
if terrico caused a split in the
timeline at the moment he arrived in the
past
everything that took place before his
arrival has to be a carbon copy of
breath of the wild's timeline
that's how timelines work it's not until
he arrives and starts changing the
outcome that events start diverging
so does this mean that this part of
creating a champion is now not canon or
did they just
retcon it to fit the gameplay oh wow
they brought back the future champions
from breath of the wild
aside from the question of how terrico
the gods or
whoever is making this happen knows how
to do this how are they not the least
bit shocked about it
they just got ripped from their own
reality only to pop up in a different
one
in the middle of a fight to the death
nonetheless speaking of which
how do they know exactly what to do as
soon as they jump out of the portal
were they stuck in limbo for a while and
someone had to fill them in
like alright younobo i know this is very
weird and you're probably in shock right
now
but i'm gonna need you to do exactly as
i say alright so any moment now you're
gonna be transported right in front of a
massive laser beam heading straight for
you
and your ancestor daruk oh yeah he's
still alive in this reality by the way
now you're gonna have to activate your
magic shield thingy right as you arrive
don't hesitate for even a second or both
the rook and you will die a horrible
fiery death
you got it now that i think about it
where were the new champions when they
got ripped from their own timeline
anyway
can you imagine if one of them was in
the bathroom at that moment
or sleeping now aside from the whole
time travel aspect there are some other
moments that just have me scratching my
head
moments where i just have to ask how or
why
as an example the blood moon rises
ganon's magic wax is strongest now the
monsters who run the land
their souls have returned how do you
know that
no seriously how do you know that as far
as we know the blood moon first appeared
during or after the
calamity and ganon himself had been
completely forgotten about
nobody knows what he is what he can do
or even what he looks like
how does she know what effects the moon
has and what it does to monsters
did she get some sort of divine
knowledge after awakening her power
if so then why did she not see the blood
moon coming why does she not know the
solution to many other issues
transpiring after her awakening
like pura being able to activate the
shika towers again and that's another
thing
i like that pura ends up being a crucial
part to the solution and all but the way
it's written just
comes off as lazy it's the typical
hacker trope
i managed to decrypt the code and get
past the firewalls and other computer
talk she's just like hey remember when i
said we couldn't teleport many people at
once yet just a few days ago
well not only did i hack the firewall
and do sciency sciency stuff to take
back control of the central unit at the
castle
but i can also teleport entire armies
now and even max the size of skyscrapers
and don't worry i've already informed
all of hyrule that i'm able to do this
while you were busy so they will all be
in battle positions once i hit the
teleport button
yes science
okay all right nintendo no just
no we all know link is a powerful and
agile dude but he's still a mortal being
made of flesh and blood
the man would pulverize his entire arm
and probably every other bone in his
body trying to pull this stunt
why couldn't he have just pushed zelda
out of the way or something
i mean damn link earlier in the story he
gets hit on the shield with a boulder
breaker and he flies like 20 feet
through the air into a wall but a solid
stone ceiling block 20 times his size
no biggie
[Music]
link what are you doing we have to hurry
the castle
it's about to collapse no worries
princess
check this out
oh wow that actually worked
there are some more of these little
moments spurred throughout the story
where i just can't ignore what i'm
seeing either because i know the
established lore
it's way too convenient as a plot device
or because it's just physically
impossible even within the fictional
world of zelda
now obviously i am nitpicking here and
hey maybe we're not supposed to think
about this stuff too much
and none of these points ultimately ruin
the experience for me by any means
but i do think it's fair to be critical
of a story and not just praise it
many of the negatives i've covered
probably won't bother the average player
or even be noticed by anyone aside from
those who are very knowledgeable and
invested in zelda lore
but even purely from a storytelling
perspective there were definitely some
things lacking
i think that astor for instance could
have been fleshed out more
it would have been nice to know why he
does what he does was he the fortune
teller who uttered the prophecy where
did he get the orb
why is he wearing gerudo clothing and
where did he get them
i also think they could have been a
little bit more clear about the fact
that ganon's malice corrupted the
present-day terrico when it followed
future terrico into the portal
not everything has to be explained in
detail but i can definitely see why some
people were confused about this part of
the narrative
a little cut scene showing the malice
taking him over and harbinger then
approaching astor for the first time and
showing him the future would have gone a
long way
anyway as not to end on a negative note
i will conclude with
the music the music kicks many asses
including mine what is there to say they
took the best and the most memorable
tracks which were already good in breath
of the wild and put them on steroids
these epic renditions are just
masterful some of my favorites being the
divine beast remixes the theme songs of
rivali and mifa
zelda's awakening and of course a fair
share of brand new tracks which all
sound great as well
they really outdid themselves here and
frankly there isn't much to say
other than a job well done for those who
thought breath of the wild lacked music
just put on the ost to age of calamity
next time you're playing that game
in conclusion though in no way as
amazing or groundbreaking as breath of
the wild
i think age of calamity is still a nice
addition to the series
for a game that came out of nowhere and
was released so quickly thereafter it
really gave me a fun experience to hold
me over until the next installment
and it was great to revisit this world
again and see it in a different light
getting to see the towns and settlements
still in their prime paired with some
fast-paced action and an
engaging story a story which in and of
itself is also harmless since in the
larger scheme of things
it doesn't invalidate or hurt the lore
established by breath of the wild
with the exception of the master sword
bit i mentioned earlier but that was
only given a backstory in creating a
champion which was written by a third
party nonetheless
other than that it doesn't change the
events of said game it might have an
impact on breath of the wild 2
story but we'll just have to wait and
see if that will be the case
and to what extent age of calamity is
not for everyone but
then again what game really is before we
close the curtains
i have a few things to note first off if
you haven't been following my community
updates
my discord is now up and running we are
rapidly moving towards 400 members but
there's always room for more
so come on down and join the maze next
up a big thanks to sam stallings for
redesigning my channel thumbnail
something he did out of his own volition
both me and the community on discord
really dig it and i immediately decided
to update it in my branding as always a
big thanks to my patreons and my channel
members of which
m phoenix and morgy t have recently
joined the cause
thank you so much and lastly of course a
big thanks to chap c
for joining me in the skit at the
beginning of the video we had a lot of
fun making this one
is i hope to see you all in the next
video this is dawn signing off and
have a good one
[Music]
you